vous rendez compte deux ans de crise de
gilles est jeune mais mais mais c'est à
afférents cefrio et aucun gouvernement
est incapable à ce point-là de gérer
cela ça aurait pu durer deux jours trois
jours une semaine
il suffisait peut-être de rétropédaler
tout de suite mais non ça a coûté
finalement des centaines et des
centaines de millions d'euros
tout simplement parce que le
gouvernement n'a pas eu envie d'agir
tout de suite de collaborer avec sa
population
ça c'est vraiment problématique cette
espèce de nos capacités de ce
gouvernement est peut-être encore plus
du jupitérien emmanuel macron de de
vouloir parler finalement avec ses
citoyens et citoyennes et ils sas est
incompréhensible et c'est très compliqué
c'est pour ça effectivement que comme ça
a été dit il ya une crise très forte
aussi de légitimité de ce gouvernement
la légitimité des manuels maquereau en
plus tient à une énorme un énorme coup
de com un énorme hold up électoral
certes andy à hold up démocratique
puisqu'il n'avait même jamais été élu
même pas comme conseiller municipal dans
une petite mairie dans une petite
commune aucune part donc il ya tout d'un
coup on se dit est ce que finalement ils
avaient la compétence de passer de
jamais élu un président ça c'est quand
même très problématique est donc
effectivement il ya un choc de confiance
qui aurait doit être rattrapé et ils
sont incapables de trouver et d'aller
chercher le chemin de ce choc de
confiance
j'en veux pour preuve évidemment macron
cet été mais j'en veux aussi pour preuve
on apparaître à l'heure donc le 1900 et
veyran est aussi évidemment jean castex
qui a géré un déconfinement en deux
temps trois mouvements qui est devenu
tout de suite premier ministre donc à
l'aisselle déconfinement on sait pas
trop à qui finalement et qui lui même
lors d'une émission récente de
télévision dit qu'il ne sait pas qu'il
ne voit plus personne que l'application
convient ne l'intéressent pas enfin
lui-même avoue quelque chose qui relève
de l'incompétence
donc c'est très compliqué et on voit
aussi autre point problématique en
politique c'est gouverner c'est prévoir
c'est peut-être un peu banal de dire ça
mais on l'a dit et tout le monde l'a dit
sur ce plateau
tout le monde pouvait savoir ce qui
allait se passer en septembre
pourquoi le goût
ornements n'a pas anticiper correctement
les choses
[Musique]